nous sommes au pied d'un immeuble de 15
étages 4 appartements sont en feu une
première équipe lutte déjà contre les
flammes une seconde évacue les habitants
les flammes se propagent rapidement le
capitaine n'a pas droit à l'erreur en
quelques secondes il décide d'envoyer
des renforts
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauvés secourir protéger
finalement j'ai changé de cap je suis
journaliste alors j'ai décidé d'aller à
la rencontre de ces hommes et de ses
femmes ordinaires qui exercent des
métiers hors du commun vous êtes dans le
camion des pompiers madame aujourd'hui
je vous emmène en plein cœur de la
capitale lutter contre les flammes
et venir en aide à la population c'est
le métier des 8550 sapeurs-pompiers de
Paris
c'est l'heure de vie et ça va devenir la
mienne
[Musique]
nous célébrons aujourd'hui la mémoire du
sergent Pedro de la 27e compagnie le
concert de Port-Royal Paris avenue 13e
arrondissement alors tous les lundi
matin sur la place d'Armes au sous-sol
d'un magasin le capot HF pélo chef
d'équipe au premier secours de Colombes
a été piégé par les flammes et ensevelie
par l'effondrement solennel
[Musique]
à l'appel
ça peut Rémi 18 noms sont cités
aux pompiers qu'il côtoie
quotidiennement la mort les 95 pompiers
de la caserne de Port-Royal ont fait un
choix celui de risquer leur vie pour
sauver celle des autres
la brigade vient de recevoir un appel
une équipe de pompiers saute dans un
camion de secours à victime ils ont 10
minutes pour intervenir le début d'une
course contre la montre
à sa tête Sarah l'une des rares femmes
de la brigade une pointe de fer et un
sourire charmeur
[Musique]
au volant Maxime
la grande gueule de l'équipe
un caractère de cochon tout dévoué à sa
mission
à l'arrière Titouan le petit dernier
18 ans
stagiaire pompier le bleu de la bande
une personne malade c'est la seule
information dont dispose Sarah Maxime et
Titouan pour le moment nous devons nous
rendre le plus rapidement possible sur
les lieux chaque minute écoulée est une
minute perdue sur leur dos le nécessaire
pour sauver la vie d'un homme n'ayant
plus de nouvelles de son ami c'est un
voisin qui a composé le 18 dans
l'appartement
il est inconscient c'est une urgence
vitale sarah est le chef d'agrès c'est
elle qui dirige l'opération
sous ses ordres Maxime et Titouan Sarah
ne panique pas elle comprend
immédiatement qu'il s'agit d'un coma
diabétique et son objectif est
d'apporter les premiers soins en
attendant les médecins
l'équipe doit prendre les premières
constances battement du cœur tension
pupille ventilation pour cibler le
niveau de gravité des symptômes
d'accord
Sarah guide le petit nouveau durant
l'intervention
et c'est avec la voix hésitante que
Titouan s'exécute
monsieur
réveillez-vous c'est les pompiers
méthode peut efficace Titouan utilise
alors un autre stratagème
quand tu veux stimuler il bouge hein
[Musique]
fortement contre le long sur une
personne consciente ça fait très très
mal donc en fait je regarde si réagit
quoi voilà si son inconscience elle est
profonde de degré de conscience d'accord
l'homme ne réagit toujours pas mauvais
signe mais Titouan ne lâche rien il faut
désormais attendre l'équipe médicale
elle arrive enfin 10 minutes plus tard
les pompiers se mettent alors à leur
disposition
[Musique]
de trouver tout ce qu'on a ici une
piqûre de glucose plus tard
la victime est totalement désorientée
la solution le visage familier de son
voisin
il faut lui parler
mission réussie pour les pompiers la vie
de cet homme ne tenait qu'à un fil et
grâce à eux il pourra reprendre d'ici
quelques jours une vie normale on peut
mourir le gars
heureusement qu'il a un bon voisin parce
que
sans son voisin
il est plus là
on peut pas faire grand-chose
puis après
on attend le SAMU ou
ou nos collègues
ceux qui m'entourent donc ça j'aime bien
la ligne
c'est pas mal mais il devra faire ses
preuves sur le terrain comme à la
caserne
d'ailleurs une mission de la plus haute
importance là-dedans
avant de manier la lance à incendie
Titouan va devoir savoir utiliser un
autre outil le balai
les pompiers de Paris comme ceux de
Marseille sont des militaires et sont
donc chargés de l'entretien de leur
caserne une tâche peut être un gratte
mais Titouan n'a qu'une seule idée en
tête
je sais que à côté de ramasser les
feuilles il y a de belles expériences à
vivre
en tout cas pour moi c'est pas ça qui va
le faire que
toujours positive toujours garder le cap
pour devenir sans doute un soldat du feu
qui dit pompier dit camion rouge chaque
véhicule à sa spécificité
ça est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
les véhicules parce qu'en fait c'est ça
détermine pas mal de choses le véhicule
auquel on est affecté
VSAV le véhicule de secours à victime
une sorte d'ambulance
il PS le premier secours d'évacuation
polyvalent
enfin le fourgon dédié exclusivement aux
incendies
[Musique]
et puis il nous reste un dernier
véhicule non l'échelle on va aller voir
les chaînes
la légendaire grande échelle un jouet de
gosse grandeur nature
[Musique]
à l'étage de la caserne la réalité tout
autre les pompiers se sont transformés
en véritable fake du logis balai en main
le moindre recoin est astiqué
aujourd'hui c'est Maxime qui joue
l'inspecteur des travaux finis
quand ils sont de garde les 95 pompiers
de la caserne de Port-Royal vivent sur
place réparties sur quatre étages 18
dortoirs de 3 à 10 lits
oh on est loin de l'hôtel 4 étoiles pas
de doute ici on est à l'armée
pour que ça soit un minimum propre on
vit ici qu'un jour par mois donc
c'est notre deuxième maison donc
chez nous on nettoie donc on est tous
ici
soudain fini le ménage
Maxime redevient pompier
c'est un appel pour une simple histoire
de porte fermée
[Musique]
l'équipe arrivait sur place est un peu
dans le flou et tente de comprendre s'il
y a urgence ou pas
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez son numéro de
téléphone
[Musique]
bon ben c'est parti silence radio depuis
24 heures il y a urgence derrière la
porte peut-être le pire
couché sur le sol une dame toujours
vivante
tu peux me dire ce qui s'est passé les
symptômes ressemblent à ceux d'une crise
d'épilepsie
et à des problèmes gastriques
cette retraité vie seul dans son
appartement
[Musique]
on va tout obligé de monter sur
depuis aujourd'hui vous avez mal au
ventre ou pas
alors attends pas d'urgence vitale les
pompiers lui font une toilette avant de
l'examiner on va faire un brin de
toilette et laissez vous faire souper
laissez vous faire ça va pas être facile
sinon
[Musique]
de routine à la victime
on est en quelle année on est en quelle
année
oui
si elle est orientée dans le temps et
dans l'espace donc où est-ce que vous
êtes en quelle année nous sommes c'est
pas forcément une bonne nouvelle pour
nous parce que ça voudrait dire qu'il y
a un souci en logique
vous avez quel âge madame vous avez quel
âge s'il vous plaît merci
la dame semble totalement perdue
les réponses sont farfelues un examen
fiable et donc compliqué
après 45 minutes au chevet de la victime
les pompiers l’installent sur un
brancard direction l'hôpital
mais en bas de l'immeuble une surprise
les attend
[Musique]
alors vous voulez qu'on se garer
on est dans l'urgence aussi il faut nous
comprendre admettons c'est quelqu'un de
votre famille on fait comment
en vous mettant là
si vous compreniez madame confronté
aussi des rangs manquent de civisme de
cette femme les pompiers gardent leur
sang-froid comme quoi leur pire ennemi
n'est pas toujours le feu
durant le trajet vers l'hôpital
la victime reprend ses esprits
derrière son masque de gros dur
[Musique]
Maxime supporte mal les plaines de cette
femme ils se sont impuissants face à sa
souffrance
ah non
celle qui c'est les médecins
ah non on est que encore une fois on est
que secouriste on a que les bases d'un
d'un secouriste donc certes on est en
équipe mais
on n'est pas on n'est pas habilité à
donner des médicaments quoi
allez madame on est arrivé mais non
madame on est arrivé là
hospitalisé à l'hôpital Cochin une
équipe médicale prend en charge la
patiente et soulageons fin sa douleur
mais le quotidien des pompiers se
déroule principalement au centre de
secours
Sarah mon guide m'introduit au coeur de
la caserne là où tout se joue la cantine
chaque jour près de 50 pompiers des
jeunes dans ce réfectoire
[Musique]
alors comment est-ce que ça se passe ici
le mot fast food a une vraie
signification manger le plus vite
possible avant que la sirène synonyme de
départ ne retentisse bien diététique
comme repasse entre sport et
intervention la nourriture doit tenir au
corps
les mecs sont pas trop les légumes
mais pas le temps de goûter à la
gastronomie militaire
[Musique]
ça sera pas pour tout de suite nous
sommes appelés sur une intervention
bon ben on a vu les hamburgers de loin
ici jamais de temps mort
interrompu juste avant d'avaler mon
burger je suis confronté à la réalité
des pompiers alors c'est quoi ça
direction la piscine de Montparnasse
pour une fois la paix est précis un ado
de 16 ans s'est foulé le petit orteil
chez les pompiers il n'y a pas de
petites interventions ils doivent
répondre présent
trois pompiers pour un orteil foulé gel
Lucine jouer le rôle de taxi c'est une
réalité qu'ils sont parfois obligé de
subir
ai pas l'idée
[Musique]
une équipe mobilisée 30 minutes pour un
petit orteil c'est une équipe en moins
pour des urgences plus sérieuses la
rotation entre les véhicules vient
d'être faites normalement en cas d'appel
c'est le deuxième VSAV qui devra sortir
nous sommes les derniers à la cantine
nous ne devrions plus être dérangés
du coup pour le SAV 1 et 4 petits coups
pour lever sa vidéo
je vais enfin retrouver mon burger
[Musique]
non
non non on peut prendre une frite
peut-être avant de partir
on vous les rend
c'est quand même un métier plein de
contraintes
c'est heureusement une fausse alerte
mais j'ai appris à devenir méfiant
pas toutes ces contraintes 14 jours de
garde plus 2 de réserves et le reste du
temps repos entre les interventions le
sport les tâches administratives et
l'entretien de la caserne ça n'est pas
du luxe
ça y est c'est le grand jour je vais
enfin me transformer en pompier
direction le garage la tenue de feu est
toujours à proximité des camions prête à
l'emploi petit détail il n'y a pas de
vestiaire
étalage de pectoraux je vais pas pouvoir
concurrencer ce genre là mon Dieu qui
sont costaud
la musculature
surdimensionnée
c'est bon
j'y suis
et donc ça ça protège du feu ah oui
c'est totalement ignifugé
le casque
je pense que ça devrait être rare que je
l'écarte un petit peu au niveau du tour
de tête où ça va c'est moyennement
confortable
le sergent
on se sent bien là on sent fort
je vais draguer maintenant
mais avant de draguer je vais jouer aux
pompiers première étape le rassemblement
face au chef du jour problème je n'ai
pas fait l'armée je suis un peu largué
est-ce le sergent adleron
[Musique]
[Rires]
déguisé en pompier c'est un peu un rêve
de mom qui se réalise mais l'habit ne
fait pas le moine et la brigade va me
faire passer un premier test
[Musique]
on sent un peu stressé en fait on sait
pas pourquoi je sais pas là parce qu'en
fait je sais pas exactement ce qu'il va
m'arriver
sans barreau 30 mètres c'est super méga
impressionnant
c'est déjà un doute sur ma capacité à
monter les barreaux parce que
tu as vu la longueur de l'échelle ils
ont l'intention de la déployer jusqu'au
bout
ça y est je commence à stresser si je me
sens pas en arrêt pourtant je suis
arnaché et lécher les sécuriser donc là
je monte
non
ça va je me sens quand même d'attaque
si vous pouvez n'hésitez pas
j'y suis bordel
j'y suis mais je dois maintenant faire
l'exercice imposé
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que j'arrive à
rentrer le pied comme ça en fait ici
sergent des sapeurs-pompiers de Paris
bon maintenant il y a plus qu'à
redescendre
je crois qu'il faut pas regarder en bas
en fait derrière soi en bas c'est pas
grave mais derrière toi
c'est super
génial merci Eric
de l'expérience
[Musique]
un service de réanimation appelé en même
temps que les pompiers la situation
s'annonce tendue
au départ
une femme enceinte en détresse ça n'est
donc pas une seule mais deux vies il
faut sauver surtout qu'à cet instant
personne ne sait si la maman a déjà
accouché ou pas Maxime au volant slalom
entre les voitures la tension est
palpable
à peine arrivé sur les lieux une femme
court à la rencontre des pompiers avec
une annonce surprenante
pas forcément une très bonne nouvelle un
nouveau né a besoin de soins précis dès
son arrivée au monde
la maman n'était pas encore à terme
c'est accouchement à domicile est une
surprise la plus totale c'est son
deuxième enfant
alors il a crié tout va bien d'accord
super c'est une petite fille un petit
garçon un petit garçon
on met les gants
à l'entrée de la chambre le papa ému et
déboussolé
est-ce que vous voulez la laisser
vous avez découvertes
le garder en vie premier danger
l'hypothermie
la température de son corps ne doit
absolument pas descendre
[Musique]
vous étiez à terme petite crevette
on va mettre le bébé à l'intérieur c'est
une un sac pour qui garde sa chaleur
donc on va essayer tu vas m'aider
à le soulever tout doucement
il a peut-être pas aussi
avec des arguments très convaincants
[Musique]
vous inquiétez pas voilà c'est bien de
l'avoir mis contre vous c'est super
madame
ça va madame
dans 5 10 minutes maximum ça peut
attendre encore vous inquiétez pas voilà
elle a un petit bonheur beau comme tout
malgré son calme apparent Sarah n'est
pas totalement sereine le placenta n'est
pas expulsé ce qui peut provoquer une
hémorragie de la délivrance la première
cause de mortalité lors d'un
accouchement normalement il y a le
médecin de Sami qui doit arriver dans
pas longtemps mais j'appelle quand même
la coordination
pour qu'il pour bien savoir si on les a
bien au départ en cas de problème seul
une équipe médicale pourrait alors
sauver cette dame
oui bonjour
on a une dame avec un bébé elle vient
d'accoucher et on en avait un SAMU au
départ mais on sait pas si il arrive ou
pas
[Musique]
ah bah c'est bon le SAMU arrive c'est
ils étaient déjà en bas merci
[Musique]
le médecin prend l'opération en main
c'est lui qui est maintenant responsable
des patients le bébé est ausculté sur le
champ et la mer prise en charge Sarah
peut enfin respirer
comme ça quand ça se passe bien
dans quelques minutes la mer et l'enfant
seront évacués vers l'hôpital le plus
proche mission accomplie pour les
pompiers de Paris de retour à la caserne
ils prennent le temps de débriefer
autour d'un café
cette intervention les a
particulièrement touchés
[Musique]
il y avait de l'excitation aussi à
l'aise parce que c'est vrai que c'est il
était tout petit en plus
courant pour nous parce que c'est vrai
que notre quotidien c'est plus la mort
mais
la mort les pompiers s'y préparent
quotidiennement aujourd'hui ces missions
de sauvetage c'est un exercice mais tout
doit être plus vrai que vrai
le type sous le masque à gaz c'est moi
je suis désigné chef de mission j'entre
donc en premier sur l'intervention
[Musique]
la descente dans la cave se fait en
marche arrière une technique pour
limiter la casse en cachette je suis
relié à Sarah par un fil d'Ariane cette
corde peut nous sauver la vie en cas de
problème notamment si l'un de nous fait
un malaise notre mission ramener une
victime à la surface mais le couloir
était trois la fumée brouille m'a vue on
se déplace avec difficulté
à quelqu'un au sol
l'homme ne répond pas il est inconscient
ou peut-être mort
nous devons le sortir au plus vite je
dois soulever ce corinaire avec Sarah 75
kg c'est pour moi tout simplement
impossible je n'y arrive pas la caporal
chef ne lâche rien
[Musique]
par cette femme force de la nature nous
remontons péniblement mon équipement me
gêne ma respiration se fait de plus en
plus difficile
va sauver la vie de cet homme
[Musique]
l'opération n'aura duré que quelques
minutes une éternité je suis épuisé
c'est limite de ce que je peux faire je
peux pas porter quelqu'un comme ça
sur les épaules
ce qui est de plus aussi gênant c'est la
ligne de vie quoi
on est toujours relié on sait où est la
sortie il faut vraiment qu'on se la
direction on va parce que si on prend
des initiatives
ça répéter ça tout le temps parce que
le jour où c'est livré
[Musique]
on a pas la chaleur donc on fait ça plus
calmement
autre outil qu'il faut savoir maîtriser
la lance à eau un gros tuyau d'arrosage
en quelque sorte je devrais pouvoir m'en
sortir
c'est pas plus que ça c'est un pipi
ça c'est le jeu le plus utilisé après
moi je pensais pas du tout que c'était
puissant de tenir
on attaque le feu
avec de l'eau quoi ouais
je comprends que pour vous ce soir la
reine des interventions
que vous avez ça depuis hier bonsoir
c'est les pompiers pour le calendrier
[Musique]
un feu combattre les flammes risquer sa
vie pour sauver celle des autres il faut
le vivre pour comprendre ce métier hors
du commun cette passion qui prend aux
tripes
être pompier n'a pas que des avantages
aujourd'hui personne ne se personne ces
missions calendrier
doit vendre environ 20 calendriers et ça
n'est pas toujours évident
[Musique]
heureusement certains ont des techniques
plus efficaces
bonsoir madame excusez-moi de vous
déranger c'est les pompiers de Paris
pour le calendrier annuel est-ce que
vous souhaitez en avoir un madame
[Musique]
sur la route pour le feu n'importe quoi
ils sont utiles heureusement qu'on les a
merci Madame 15 € c'est beaucoup 15
euros
nom
par rapport à notre secteur c'est un peu
plus que la moyenne donc Madame fait un
très bon
donc je vous remets madame votre
calendrier ma petite touche
ce don sera totalement reversé à leur
association dédiée entre autres
orphelins des pompiers je vous remercie
beaucoup au revoir merci homme femme
enfant personne ne résiste aux charmes
de Jérémy le mythe du pompier de Paris
est à l'oeuvre et voilà pour vous et il
ne recule devant rien même face au
tirelire des ados
[Musique]
merci beaucoup bonsoir c'est les
pompiers pour le calendrier
rien ne semble entamer la bonne humeur
de Jérémy au revoir pas même les
fantômes
certaines personnes qui
font le fantôme donc généralement ils
voient que dans leur petit
œil tombent c'est les pompiers et là il
pense que discrètement ou par temps
moule que on les entendra pas seulement
généralement les enfants
en deux heures jérémy a vendu 20
calendriers et récolter 160 euros pour
l'association merci beaucoup bonne
soirée au revoir merci beaucoup
supérieurs avec les caches sous les
fumées c'est toujours toi
[Musique]
ça pousse beaucoup là derrière la porte
j'ai toujours pas m'avez de ça au volant
le capitaine Christophe piemontési
appelé d'urgence sur un incendie près
des maréchaux une centaine de pompiers
sont attendus sur place c'est une très
grosse intervention avec le message
[Musique]
parce qu'on sait pas sur quoi on va
arriver
ce soir c'est lui qui dirige
l'intervention c'est lui qui gère
l'ensemble des équipes
nous sommes au pied d'un immeuble de 15
étages 4 appartements sont en feu une
première équipe lutte déjà contre les
flammes une seconde évacue les habitants
pour prendre des commandes de
l'opération le capitaine fait un état de
la situation
les flammes se propage rapidement le
capitaine n'a pas droit à l'erreur en
quelques secondes il décide d'envoyer
des renforts
le feu se situe à 40 mètres du sol la
grande échelle est inutilisable il faut
attaquer les flammes par l'intérieur le
capitaine en voie notre équipe au combat
et c'est parti pour une montée en enfer
le gaz et l'électricité sont coupés les
ascenseurs hors-service et c'est à la
lampe torche avec plus de 20 kg de
matériel sur le dos que les pompiers
grimpent les 13 étages qui les sépare
des flammes
là il y a l'équipe
de sécurité ici
[Musique]
au total 14 casernes sont mobilisés le
capitaine piémontaisi est le seul maître
à bord un poste de commandement est
installé dans la rue c'est d'ici qu'il
suit le travail de ses hommes et leur
donne des ordres
le feu est presque circonscrit mais la
fumée a envahi les trois derniers étages
il y a risque d'intoxication les
habitants sont a priori tous évacués
mais le capitaine fait quand même ouvrir
tous les appartements à risque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après deux longues heures de lutte
l'incendie est enfin maîtrisé tous les
appartements ouverts et vidés le
capitaine peut se rendre compte par
lui-même du travail de ces hommes
les quatre appartements sont détruits le
feu a tout dévoré il ne reste
pratiquement rien seulement quelques
vestiges d'une vie partie en fumée en
moins d'une heure
moi je vais descendre
[Musique]
les gens qui habitent là donc il faut
bien se rendre compte qu'ils ont perdu
les photos tout est tous les bijoux donc
là c'est un choc qui s'effondre
complètement parce que là il faut
imaginer chez nous si ça va on est tous
pareils
mais le capitaine piémontaisir plutôt
satisfait les dégâts auraient pu être
beaucoup plus important dans cet
immeuble de 15 étages
[Musique]
quand il y a un faux deuxième étage
encore plus que quand il y a un feu au
dernier étage tout en voilà ça s'adresse
limité au niveau au dessus supérieur
toujours donc là on est juste en dessous
c'est propre en plus il y a des moyens
de secours il y a des portefeu donc il y
a pas beaucoup de risques au niveau sur
inférieur il y a rien en fait la
pression peut enfin redescendre bilan
zéro mort de blesser léger 4
appartements en moins et quelques
familles à reloger
et sur le visage des soldats le sourire
celui de la victoire c'est pour ça c'est
pour ces moments là cette poussée
d'adrénaline qu'ils font ce métier
après quatre heures d'intervention le
capitaine piémontaisi peut enfin
souffler lui aussi
[Musique]
enfin on rentre à la maison
on va aller prendre une douche
ça s'est bien passé
[Musique]
victime enfin habitant et niveau côté
pompier donc voilà donc ça s'est bien
passé
[Musique]
il est une heure du matin les véhicules
sont rentrés à la caserne tout le monde
dort enfin presque on va se coucher
allez
juste à côté du poste de commandement il
y a une chambre utilisée par les
pompiers de garde ce soir c'est la
mienne
mais ça sent bon on dirait l'hôpital
pourtant ils sont tous propres
sur les bottes et on rentre dans le
pantalon
et voilà
bonne nuit je vous dis à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure dormez bien ouais
je suis en bas ouais
allez bonne nuit
je vais rester habillé ce serait quand
même dommage de partir en intervention
en caleçon à mon avis de la nuit
[Musique]
donc moi je vais rester comme ça
ma stratégie
allez bonne nuit maintenant c'est
appartient à mon intimité
et pour une fois j'ai de la chance la
nuit sera calme
comme chaque lundi à 10 heures le cri
résonne sur la place d'Armes
comme un éternel à peine
indispensable
après l'appel mort une surprise attend
Sarah l'accueil
bonjour
[Musique]
vous allez bien c'est Laurine la toute
jeune maman qui a couché à domicile
accompagnée de son bébé Sacha
[Musique]
de mes enfants donc faut que je prenne
une petite photo avec
voilà
on a des courriers des petites cartes
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez rare que
les gens se déplacent et ça fait très
plaisir
surtout un petit bébé aussi beau
[Musique]
le
lendemains pour 2013 obligatoire
[Musique]
je te souhaite une vie remplie de
bonheur
la visite du bébé et de sa maman la plus
belle récompense pour Sarah comme
l'aboutissement d'un choix de vie après
le quart d'heure pouponnage il est temps
pour Sarah de rentrer chez elle
sa chambre est au 4e et dernière étage
de la caserne au bout d'un petit couloir
un coin à part réservé aux filles
[Musique]
comme c'est mignon c'est tout rose
donc tu dors là combien de nuit par
semaine une nuit par semaine parce que
je suis permanente et je prends une
garde par semaine
je retourne chez moi m'occuper de ma
fille et puis de mon mari
fin de la journée voilà c'est ça enfin
de la journée à la brigade et début de
journée en tant que maman
qui emmène rien là-bas
c'est bien de couper aussi
de voir autre chose enfin de parler
d'autre chose
[Rires]
tu te remercies
pompiers la journée épouse et maman le
soir
[Musique]
c'est quasiment militaire comme tu dis
bon ben bonne soirée
et
[Musique]
à tout de suite à très vite bisous
au revoir
de mes belles rencontres chez les
pompiers de Paris
d'autres n'ont pas terminé leur journée
nous sommes appelés pour une
intervention près des grands boulevards
dans le 13e arrondissement un sans-abri
on est en décembre les températures sont
proches de zéro dormir dehors devient
dangereux
mais on l'a trouvé par terre un sac
poubelle sur la tête on se demandait
s'il respirait bien et bougez pas qu'on
lui a demandé si
vous voulez de l'aide il a dit que on a
appelé les pompiers monsieur faut
vraiment les appeler pour vous parce que
là on va rentrer dans la phase vraiment
il va faire vraiment froid venir au
secours des sans-abris c'est courant
pour les pompiers cet homme d'une
cinquantaine d'années très affaibli ça
température est proche de 36 degrés
c'est correct vous commencez à voir un
peu froid mais c'est correct d'accord ce
soir il n'y a pas d'urgence vitale il y
a surtout besoin de reprendre des forces
de trouver un lieu aussi pour dormir au
chaud mais en cette période les foyers
sont encore fermés son seul refuge
l'hôpital
la raison de votre stérilisation
[Musique]
nous avons mis du liquide dedans
d'accord mais on voulait enlever cette
perfusion normalement alors et là
l'équipe découvre l'inimaginable si
c'est juste pour envoyer du sérum
et vous êtes partis avec l'accord de
où j'ai rien dit vous allez c'est parti
on s'est vu qu'il est parti tout seul
les pompiers ne comprennent pas comment
cette personne peut encore avoir sa
perfusion dans le monde
ça fait combien de temps que vous avez
ça depuis hier
c'est hier qui vous l'ont mis vous êtes
sûr vous n'êtes pas parti 100 qui vous
l'enlève les pompiers sont scotchés cet
homme aux conditions de vie difficiles
risque une grave infection
l'équipe était émue par l'histoire de ce
sans-abris à l'arrière du SAV l'ambiance
est étrange pendant le trajet Maxime va
lui glisser discrètement deux
couvertures de survie dans son blouson
c'est juste qu'on aimerait pas vivre au
ski donc
leur mouvement sont délicats presque
maternel vous avez mal aux jambes
[Musique]
les pompiers s'identifient à cet homme
comme
[Musique]
avec le Samu Social essayer de choper
des vêtements d'hiver
ça m'interpelle parce que ça pourrait
nous arriver demain
fin de contrat on peut tout se retrouver
dans la rue ça va super vite
la descente aux enfers
[Musique]
donc on peut pas se permettre de juger
derrière une solide carapace une belle
humanité
elle est reçue ça y est mon séjour à la
brigade de Port-Royal touche à sa fin je
pensais tout connaître des pompiers je
me trompais derrière un numéro le 18
j'ai découvert des hommes et une femme
un gros puni à la vie et à la mort
dernier moment avec eux un verre à la
main
il est déjà l'heure pour moi de repartir
à la découverte de nouveaux horizons ou
ma tante d'autres hommes et d'autres
femmes au métier exceptionnel